- This is Woodhenge.
This was a smaller
monument consisting
of six concentric
rings of wooden posts
that pointed up towards the
sky as much as 4,000 years ago.
And this monument itself
being circular in the same way
that Stonehenge was
suggests to us that the 19
stones around the
edge of Durrington
was a huge great circle
in itself, the largest
ring of stones
anywhere in Europe,
perhaps even in the world.
NARRATOR: Incredibly, the newly
discovered Superhenge hedge
is not all that has been
uncovered beneath the earth
here.
Since July 2010, an
international team of experts,
as part of the Stonehenge
Hidden Landscapes Project,
has been mapping the entire area
using the latest technology.
More than 15 underground
sites have been found.
The landscape
around Stonehenge
is actually archeologically
very, very rich.
Rather than Stonehenge
being this monument that
sits by itself in Salisbury
Plain, what has been revealed
is that it is part of a
vast sacred landscape that
once covered Salisbury
Plain and went all
the way down to the river Avon.
MAN: There's no doubt that
these finds will cause
English archeologists to
have to revisit everything
we know about Stonehenge.
Because Stonehenge is not
going to be considered
an isolator, something
that's curious.
NARRATOR: While mainstream
scientists believe Stonehenge
and its surrounding sites
were ancient ritual and burial
grounds, there is
no written record
to explain why ancient people
chose to move and erect
massive blocks that weigh
up to 50 tons, some of which
were transported from
over 100 miles away.
And now that a second
Stonehenge has been found,
the theory that these sites
were simply burial grounds
has been thrown into
greater question.
DAVID WHITEHEAD:
These ancient people
had a great deal of
knowledge about how to align
these structures perfectly.
So we're dealing with an
advanced civilization,
to say the least.
Where they had that knowledge,
where they got that knowledge,
where they developed
the ability to put these
incredible monuments together--
it boggles the mind.
NARRATOR: Archeologists believe
that Stonehenge's two rings
of standing stones may be simply
the remains of a much larger
structure, based on the
presence of the earthen
hedge that surrounds it.
This has led to speculation
that Superhenge also contained
additional rings, and that
these structures might
even have had walls and roofs.
But if true, was this area of
England much more than simply
a site of religious ceremony?
When we look to these
extraordinary structures
on Earth, it makes you
wonder, did extraterrestrials
have a hand in creating
these massive monuments,
or did they teach humans how
to build these monuments?
So you have to wonder what
the purpose of these giant stone
circles are around the world?
It's impossible
they were some kind
of spaceport or conceived city.
NARRATOR: Is it
possible that Stonehenge
and the many structures
that surround it
are the remnants of an
extraterrestrial spaceport?